this is a Fox News Alert welcome to
Hannity and tonight explosive new
evidence in what is becoming the biggest
scandal or at least one of them in
American history now it's something we
have been saying would be exposed for
months according to new reports tonight
from the hills John Solomon and Circa
News's Sarah Carter there are brand new
FBI documents that show the Russian
nuclear industry officials kickback
millions and millions of dollars to the
Clinton Foundation all while Hillary
Clinton was Secretary of State and
helped approve the uranium 1 deal which
gave Moscow Russia Vladimir Putin
control of 20% of American uranium the
foundational materials for nuclear
weapons and tonight they're also
reporting the FBI now has evidence that
Russia for years has been doing this and
they're reporting the FBI has evidence
that literally they use bribery to gain
control over America's uranium industry
all while the Obama administration did
nothing and the Clintons benefited to
the tune of nearly a hundred and forty
five million dollars you want a real
Russia collusion story we've got it all
so is Congress now going to do its job
will they investigate these explosive
reports immediately well the Special
Counsel Robert Muller start looking into
this Russian plot to control American
uranium and is the left-wing mainstream
media are they going to stop pushing
their lies and conspiracy theories to
you the American people will they ever
tell us the truth and that's not all we
have tonight the FBI has confirmed that
in fact the disgraced former director
James Comey drafted a letter exonerating
Hillary Clinton months before
interviewing any key witnesses in the
email server scandal we're going to
cover all of this in tonight's breaking
news opening monologue
[Music]
all right so the hills John Solomon his
colleague over there Allison Spann are
once again out with an explosive new
report take a look at this headline from
today FBI uncovered Russian bribery plot
before Obama administration approved
controversial nuclear deal with Moscow
now here's the headline from Sarah
Carter Russia nuclear firm under FBI
investigation was allowed to purchase
u.s. uranium supply according to these
breaking news reports back in 2009 the
FBI they started gathering evidence
including recordings and emails and
witnesses that they talked to showing
that the Russian nuclear industry
officials used bribes kickbacks money
laundering and other illegal tactics to
expand Russia's influence over America's
uranium market now in the hill report
they explained that despite all of the
evidence that they had of wrongdoing
against Russia the Obama Justice
Department for some unknown reason chose
not to act and pursue charges what did
they do instead the Obama administration
then went on to approve business deals
that benefited Russia Putin Moscow
greatly while these threats to our
national security were actually going on
these include the 2010 we've talked
about it a lot now we have more details
that uranium one deal Hillary Clinton
she signed off on it she helped to prove
it that gave Vladimir Putin control over
20% of America's uranium uranium is the
foundational material so you can build
nuclear weapons we'll have a lot more on
that in just a second and the 2011 deal
that made it easier for the Russian
nuclear subsidiary to sell uranium to US
nuclear power plants now the FBI
officials told Sarah Carter at circa
news that the bureau's bribery
investigation could have actually been
stopped however this part is inexcusable
both reports highlight how the Obama
administration kept all of this evidence
that they had they had a Russian bribery
secret from Congress and the American
people until five years after the
approval of that uranium one day
and when the DOJ finally did go public
this was 2015 it was only to announce a
single charge against the Russian at the
center of the bribery scheme and they
played it on the down-low now keep in
mind after President Trump won in
November President Obama and his
administration they were telling anyone
who would listen Russia Russia Russia
Russia interfered with our election
Russia was creating a direct threat to
American democracy
well if that's the case why when they
had mountains of evidence that we will
reveal tonight of Russian bribery going
back to 2009 why then did the Obama
administration and Hillary in particular
sign off on the sale of 20% of America's
uranium to Vladimir Putin and the
Russians and speaking of uranium 1
according to the new report from the
hill
the FBI has evidence including
eyewitness accounts that quote Russian
nuclear officials routed pay attention
routed millions of dollars to the u.s.
designed to benefit former President
Bill Clinton former Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton's Charitable Foundation
during the exact time Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton served on a government
body that provided a favorable decision
to Moscow uranium one sound familiar and
by the way we can't forget Peter
Schweitzer he originally exposed this
uranium 1 deal in his best-selling book
Clinton cash now all of that is why for
months on this program I have been
telling you uranium 1 will be one of the
biggest scandals this country is ever
see just in case you forgot let's remind
you then there's the real Russia
collusion story the rhenium 1 deal which
I predict will be the biggest news to
come out in the next year or two where
the Secretary of State remember she
approved handing over up to 20% of
America's uranium the foundational
material of nuclear weapons the Vladimir
Putin and the Russians all while people
involved in the deal in Canada they
kicked back over 145 million dollars to
the Clinton Foundation Bill Clinton
doubled his speaking fees in Moscow
tonight with his new evidence what we
have discovered is the evidence against
the Clintons is overwhelming it is in
controvert Abel Hillary Clinton and her
husband sold out America to the Russians
while millions of dollars flowed to
their family foundation and in the
process Clinton helped create a massive
national security risk for every man
woman and child giving Vladimir Putin
control over American uranium and
material as I said you use it to make
nuclear warheads
now if the liberal ideological
mainstream media and the Democrats in
this country that have been screaming
Russia Russia Russia for all these
months if they want real Russia
collusion we've got it for them the
evidence is right here it doesn't even
need to be investigated just corroborate
it so it's time tonight that I'm calling
on Congress I'm calling on Robert
Mueller the special counsel stop wasting
our time and our money trying to find
evidence of Trump Russia collusion
you've been on this for a year so far
you haven't presented one shred of
evidence except now you can actually
follow facts and evidence that we do
have on the record I'm also calling out
the Attorney General jeff Sessions
tonight he recused himself from the
Russia probe he needs to now do the same
the evidence now shows that Hillary
Clinton the Obama administration put
this country in danger handing Russia
America's Iranian even though as the
hill reported there were crimes bribery
and worse and blackmail being committed
and where was the liberal mainstream
media during all of this the media
that's been running wild with all kinds
of conspiracy theories about President
Trump and Russia for months and months
and months with no evidence well here
are some of the more unhinged examples
of the left listen to their language it
applies to them tonight it applies to
the Clintons tonight it applies to Obama
tonight watch this but first we want to
start with this week in Russia gate it
is as if there are no shoes on the Trump
Human Centipede
that are not about Russia Russia Russia
Russia this cloud about collusion with
Russia will hang over him no matter
where he stands certainly feels like
we're in the opening stages of a
devastating political chapter in
American history evidence is mounting
for the president's meddling in the
Russia probe
Tom Friedman said the election hacking
is at the caliber of a Pearl Harbor or a
9/11 do you agree with that I completely
agree with that Donald Trump now sits at
the threshold of impeachment I
personally think it's over I don't think
there's anything that can be done that
can stop this at this point cacophony
this gushing of lies problems questions
chaos that will stop this presidency in
its tracks you told The Washington Post
last week that quote there's a smell of
treason in the air when it comes to this
investigation a lot of people are afraid
to use the T word treason but in the end
that's what people are investigating it
does look like collusion it does look
like he's listening to Putin more than
he has American intelligence and frankly
I've never seen that before the media
has been breathless and hysterical over
the Russia coverage yet have you heard
any of them even mention Hillary Clinton
colluding with Vladimir Putin on uranium
one has the media that's supposed to be
trusted ever reported on the millions of
dollars that were poured into the
Clinton Foundation as a result of this
deal will the press even now bother to
look at John Solomon and Sarah Carter's
reporting and do their own digging and
while we're at it did anyone in the
media aside from this show did they ever
ask Julian Assange about who gave him
he's the one that has the information
who gave him Hillary Clinton in the
DNC's emails we actually asked him and
Julian Assange told us repeatedly five
times that I've interviewed him it was
in the Russians there's also the fake
news Christopher Steele dossier that was
funded in part by the Democratic donors
guess what that dossier relied heavily
on Russian sources of false mir-2 then
candidate Donald Trump now some of the
media and some Democrats even repeated
these bogus claims remember the Ritz
hookers you're not eating on a bed they
paid for those lies by the way is that
not spreading Russia propaganda is that
not fake news is that not trying Russia
trying to influence America's election
with fake news Catherine Harridge is
reporting tonight that two members of
the firm behind that fake news dossier
have been subpoenaed to appear before
Congress as it turns out tomorrow
now the lawyer for fusion GPS is saying
tonight his client has been advised to
plead the fifth if they're forced to
show up you know what if members of
fusion GPS if they don't want to appear
before Congress they were refusing to
talk let's hold them in contempt of
Congress maybe they'll go to jail
let's see but back to the media they
continue in this country to be exposed
as a bunch of rigid radical left-wing
ideologues they do not care about the
truth and as I've been saying for years
journalism in America is dead it's
buried we have an informational crisis
in this country and it's why you the
American people no longer trust the
press nor should you look at this PBS
Marist Poll from over the summer a
combined 68 percent said they have not
very much or no trust at all in the
media and for good reason the media is
completely abusively biased in this
country they're a bunch of overpaid
rigid left-wing radical ideologues and
they no longer care about truth for
example the network evening newscast
tonight even though these massive news
stories are out about Hillary Clinton
the Obama administration colluding with
the Russians giving them uranium
kickbacks to the Clinton Foundation they
didn't even report on it it's because it
doesn't fit their narrative they're
talking points there's also the fact
that those stories are proof positive
that Russia collusion hysteria is now
starting a boomerang back on the
Democrats it's something by the way I
predicted would happen back in June take
a look
I've been saying that this is all gonna
boo meringue back no evidence do I
anybody in any Russia collusion 11
months of media lying and conspiracy
theories but it did open up the door
that okay now we got to look at Loretta
now we got to look at Hillary and I
would argue Hillary's gonna be right
behind Loretta Lynch in terms of
investigation issues what I said back in
June is exactly what is happening now
and it's only gonna get worse for
Hillary Clinton Bill Clinton the
Democrats the media and all in the left
also tonight the FBI they release proof
that the former director of the FBI
James Comey had been drafting a letter
to exonerate Hillary Clinton in her
email server scandal months before
interviewing key witnesses including the
former Secretary of State
does this not prove what I've been
saying we don't have equal justice under
the law we have a two-tiered justice
system in the in this country one for
the Clintons and one for the rest of us
and it also proves James Comey acted
inappropriately he deserved to be fired
now Comey played politics he let Clinton
off the hook even though she had secret
top-secret special access program
classified information stored let's see
in a mom-and-pop shop bathroom closet
which by the way mishandling of
classified information
that's a crime destroying classified
information that's a crime deleting
33,000 subpoenaed emails
oh that's called obstruction of justice
and unlike the mainstream media we care
about the truth here we care about facts
it's why we continue to expose all of
these scandals and tonight a new level
breaking news and this will now come
back bribery kickbacks quid pro quo
America's national security at stake